what's going on guys today we're gonna
be ranking the top eight fights that
need to happen before the end of my here
academia
with the way things are looking right
now the series doesn't have that many
more years to go
considering that chapter 306 was
literally called the final act begins
and when it's all over there are certain
battles that we'll hopefully get to see
by then
midoriya vs 100 sugaraki is obviously
one of them since it will probably end
up being the final fight
but there are of course several others
that we'll be discussing before we get
into it let me know in the comments down
below what are some of your most
anticipated fights
and then at the end you can see how many
of them were selected i'd also
appreciate if you smash that sub button
as we are on the long road to 400k
and drop a like if you want to see more
stuff like this
okay so in eighth place is a clash
between two characters who have
currently never met each other
but the nature of their quirks means it
would be super interesting the fight
here is shoto todoroki versus getting
and i'm gonna break down the reasons why
it ranks in the top eights for starters
getting has the ability to manipulate
all ice within a specific radius
and control its movement shape and its
temperature with his mind the
consequence is that anything shoto
creates with his icy side could actually
be turned against him so he'd have to
solely rely on his fire to win
this is something he rarely ever has to
do and in a life or death situation
against a really strong villain
it's possible he might have some kind of
quirk awakening big spoiler warning
ahead
but during my then academia we saw that
getting and derby were pretty much
evenly matched
despite darby having the elemental
advantage with his fire given that his
blue flames are even stronger than
shoto's
it implies the youngest todoroki sibling
would definitely have a hard time
winning against this villain
and that's why it's the perfect opponent
to force him to improve
in the manga it was revealed that
toyotaroki awakened his blue flames when
he was 13 years old
and i think shoto had that same
potential it's just that for a long time
he refused to even use his fight aside
had he been consistently training it
he'd likely already have the stronger
blue flames
however a battered against getting might
be enough to trigger it
in seventh place we have toger against
hawks which is a matchup that i think
could result in someone dying
as of making this video toga's location
is completely unknown but there are two
relevant bits of information that make
me think they'll eventually come face to
face
number one is that she's still grieving
the loss of twice who she knows was
killed by hawks
and number two is that her
transformation quirk allows her to
infiltrate the heroes and attack him at
any moment
it's pretty clear to me that togo would
want revenge if possible because not
only did hawke's kill twice but he then
justify doing it on live tv
there's no way she lets him get away
with that so it's fair to assume that at
some point she'll transform into someone
the hawks trust
best genius is a possible option
considering she might have stolen his
blood back when his body was in
possession of the villains
but then again i'm not sure she'd have
the foresight to do that
regardless of who she pretends to be it
has to be someone who can get close to
hawks and then when she's in position
she can stab him in the back in the same
way he did it twice if this takes place
it would hands down be one of the most
shocking moments in my
academia history and possibly could be
the beginning of the end for the number
two hero
moving on to the next fight that needs
to happen this one is between mr
compress and gentle who both have very
similar vibes since the beginning
congress has always been a bit of a
performer who likes to show off what he
can do
while gentle is exactly the same with
the one difference being he's a youtuber
as well
as a fellow content creator i'd love to
see him come back and i am 100 certain
it will happen in the near future
the reason i'm so sure is because back
in chapter 305 we got a page that showed
muscular stain overhaul and team gentle
and since then literally all of them
made an appearance except these two
it's therefore only a matter of time
until they come back and next time
around you'd hope they'd be on the hero
side of things
if we look at season 4 they weren't
really the most evil villains to begin
with
and at the end of the cultural festival
it was suggested it wasn't too late for
gentle to turn his life around
so whether he becomes a hero in training
or a vigilante him and lebron going up
against congress is something this
series needs
besides the amazing one-liners that
would end up coming out of this there's
also the simple fact that their quirks
would be great to see against each other
normally congress is used for either
trapping enemies who are in close range
or throwing things at people who are
further away
but gentle's quirk is almost the perfect
counter the elastic air he creates can
be used to rebound whatever gets thrown
at him
and it also prevents people from getting
too close to the activator in the right
places
in this way he has a solid defense
against compress although it will still
be difficult for him to actually win
without getting close
and in doing so he might risk being
turned into a marble
midoriya vs bakugo comes in at number 5
and this future rematch will hopefully
take place after deku has unlocked all
his quirks
if we look back to the sports festival
bakayo prefers to beat people when
they're at their best because that way
his victory will never be questioned
hence why he was severely pissed when
todoroki held back against him
for that same reason he'd want deku to
go all out during any rematch they might
have
so he can prove superior despite the big
disadvantage
on paper this matchup is no longer as
fair as it used to be obviously
however bakugou is confident that he can
be the best only one quirk
so if he thinks it's possible then we
have to acknowledge he might find a way
to win
next up is the battle of the gods that
would be all for one versus shigeraki
which is something that might happen
sooner than we think
for most of his life tomorrow believed
that afo was a caring father figure that
wanted him to be a successor
but as we found out during the war that
isn't exactly the case all for one had
instead been grooming shigeraki to
become a person so
hateful that his hatred would override
the will of one for all and in the
process enable it to be stolen
being used like this is not something
shiggy had anticipated and what makes it
even worse is that his master now
seemingly wants to steal his body for
himself
if tomorrow wants to survive which he
probably does then his first step needs
to be
somehow defeating the afo vessels in his
head and then killing the real all for
one soon afterwards
a clash between these two is necessary
if he's going to you know move on and be
the main villain
and in true star wars fashion it's only
natural that the student kills the
master
in third place we have a flashback to
the original all might vs afo fight that
occurred years before the first episode
and this encounters the event that led
to all for one needing darth vader style
equipment to stay alive
despite being so important there's a lot
we don't know about it besides the
possibility that sir naitai gran torino
and possibly dr garaki were all nearby
we still have no idea what quirks afo
had at the time we have no idea where
they fought and we also don't know how
old might dealt the finishing blow
so some time before the end of my
academia this this is just something we
need to see
i don't care if they do it in vigilantes
or make a special one-off episode or
even do it in a movie
it just needs to happen in some form
because otherwise there will be like
just this whole
that we just like will always be
wondering what was it like you know
so yeah it would be good to see it
coming in at number two is deku vs
shigeraki
and like i said in the intro it's
virtually guaranteed to be the final
fight of the series
the original ending of maher academy was
meant to have bakago and azuku sharing
one for all as they go to defeat the
final villain who i assume was going to
be shigaraki
but since that ending was already using
hero's rising horukoshi is gonna have to
think of something else
luckily for him a matchup between two
people with multiple quirks allows for
nearly endless possibilities
so i'm sure it will be great however
suguraki's super regeneration does give
him a clear advantage
being the main protagonist is
unavoidable that in the end azuka will
win
so the real question for me is will
shigaraki survive and what will deku
lose in the process
for example his classmates might be in
the firing line if tomorrow goes on a
rampage
and if someone gets hurt then midoriya
would personally regret that for the
rest of his life
overall this is a fight that i'm really
looking forward to a lot but the number
one spot goes to a battle that will
break the internet if it happens
for those of you who are new to the
channel last year i did a video called
the w generation theory in which i
theorized why shiguraki will use afo to
give his allies an extra quirk
the main example was that he'd give a
regeneration power to darby
but some time after that video came out
we got new information that changed a
few things
in chapter 301 it was confirmed that
toyota's body was built to withstand
freezing temperatures
meaning from birth he was suited for an
ice quirk instead of the fire one he
inherited
that made me think that if he was going
to get a new quirk it should be an icy
one made for his constitution
and that way he would evolve into a
direct parallel of his younger brother
from toya's own perspective he was
discarded and then replaced by shoto
so to fight his dad is like the evil
version of his perfect creation
i think that would be pretty incredible
with access to both flames and ice
darby could cool himself down whenever
he starts to overheat and choose between
either
element when he wants to attack for that
reason it's the number one fight i want
to happen
especially considering the backstory of
their relationship gives it so much more
meaning compared to a lot of the other
fights on this list
i personally don't think endeavour's
guilty conscience would allow him to go
100 against toya
which does give his crazy son the
advantage whereas ng will want to try
his hardest to bring toya back into the
light
darby's only focus is ending endeavour's
life in the most painful and ironic way
he can
he initially tried to do this in the war
arc by using prominence burn to kill him
but perhaps next time we'll see him do a
flash freeze heat wave instead
by the way i'm not saying that it's a
sure thing that dabby will get a nice
quirk
however what i am saying is that if it
does happen that would make this my
number one most anticipated fight
anyway guys thank you for watching this
video and let me know in the comments
what are the matchups that you're most
looking forward to
i'm interested to see if there are
others that i may be left out that were
even more epic than the ones i chose
um so yeah do do let me know also don't
forget to hit that sub button if you
haven't already
and until the next one peace out